Hi zusammen! Wir machen heute No Bake Kirsch-Schnitten.
Kirsch-Schnitten! Sag das mal 3x hintereinander!
[Hamza] Kirsch-Schnitten, Kirsch-Schnitten, Kirsch-Schnitten!
Kir-Schnitt! Das Wort wird dann zu Kir-Schnitten!
Wir machen auf jeden Fall Kirsch... Schnitten! Ja, ne? Und zwar No Bake.
Ich hab mich voll damit befasst gerade weil ich die ganze Zeit gesagt habe:
"Wie soll ich das Rezept nennen? Kirsch-Schnitten? Das ist voll der Zungenbrecher!
Egal, wir machen jetzt Kirsch-Schnitten.
Ich lege direkt los weil das auch ein sehr schnelles und ein praktisches Rezept ist.
Dafür nehmt ihr euch Butterkekse, mahlt die klein
- oder alternativ nehmt ihr einfach ein Nudelholz mit 'nem Gefrierbeutel,
das funktioniert auch immer wunderbar.
Gebt da geschmolzene Butter dazu und das ist unser No Bake Boden.
Jetzt habe ich hier - das kennt ihr schon von mir - meinen Backrahmen
und untendrunter meinen Kuchenheber, das ist immer so das perfekte Konstrukt für mich.
Und da gebe ich jetzt meinen Keksboden rein und drücke den schön flach an.
So der Boden ist ready, den gebe ich ganz kurz zur Seite.
Und hier habe ich schonmal alles für meine Creme bereit stehen.
Das ist jetzt eine Creme, die ich sehr, sehr mag, nämlich bestehend aus
Sahne, Mascarpone und Doppelrahmfrischkäse.
[Hamza] Ich wollte grad eigentlich den Teller zeigen!
[Kiki] Nein, brauchst du noch nicht zeigen!
Ich wollte nur kurz was sagen, ich habe mir nämlich Gedanken gemacht über das Rezept.
Da hab ich mir erst überlegt: Machst du 'en Puddingcreme?
Dann hab ich gedacht: Nee, dann muss man warten bis es abkühlt und, und, und!
Das soll ein schnelles, einfaches und leckeres Rezept werden.
Und der Schnelligkeit halber mache ich jetzt diese Creme.
Momentchen Leute... da, das hatt ich nämlich vergessen!
Und da gebe ich jetzt alles in meine Küchenmaschine und schlage das dann erst langsam,
dann immer schneller werdend und dann müsst ihr ein genaues Auge drauf haben.
Dann seht ihr nämlich wenn es soweit ist, dass die Sahne auch fest ist
und nicht zu viel schlagen, sonst überschlagt ihr es und dann gerinnt die Creme.
Und währenddessen natürlich auch schon Sahnefest einrieseln lassen
damit es auch richtig schön fest wird.
Und generell ist es immer super, wenn ihr z.B. Mascarpone oder Frischkäse als Bestandteil einer Creme verwendet
weil dann ist sie eben auch schneller schnittfest und bleibt dann auch schnittfest.
Anders als jetzt z.B. Quark oder sowas.
So, und jetzt gebe ich die Creme einmal auf den Boden und streiche sie richtig schön glatt.
So, ich säubere den Rand jetzt noch für die Kirschen gleich.
So, jetzt kommt der krönende Abschluss, nämlich unsere Kirschen.
Und da habe ich jetzt die Kirschen aufgefangen, ich hab ganz einfach Kirschen aus dem Glas genommen
- die braucht ihr gleich erst - und den Saft hier in einen Topf gegeben.
Der Herd ist noch aus, da gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen Zucker dazu.
Wenn der Saft euch schon zu süß ist oder süß genug ist, dann lasst ihn einfach weg.
Gebe da auch noch ein bisschen Vanille mit rein, einfach für das Aroma
damit's nochmal richtig schön durchkommt der Vanillegeschmack.
Und dann benutze ich heute Agar Agar, das ist pflanzliches Geliermittel.
Das kennt ihr bestimmt schon aus meinen anderen Videos, das könnt ihr dann anstelle von Gelatine z.B. benutzen.
Davon gebe ich jetzt auch etwas hier rein, rühre das um
schalte dann den Herd ein und lasse das 2min lang sprudelnd kochen.
Danach rühre ich erst die Kirschen unter damit die nicht so matschig werden.
Und die Kirschmasse am besten nochmal 15min lang einfach stehen lassen
damit's so ein bisschen runterkühlen kann damit die jetzt auch nicht ganz so heiß auf die Sahne kommt,
sonst flockt das und dann habt ihr eben kein schönes Ergebnis mehr.
Und das gebe ich jetzt ganz vorsichtig auf die Oberfläche.
Ich hab jetzt nochmal alles zusammen für 1h in den Kühlschrank getan,
jetzt ist oben die Schicht natürlich fest, die Creme ist etwas fester
und ich würd' das Ganze jetzt einmal herauslösen mit meinem Backformlöser.
Ihr könnt das Ganze auch am Vortag zubereiten
und dann die ganze Nacht in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Falls die Frage aufkommt, hier schonmal die Antwort:
Das Ganze hält sich 3 Tage lang wenn ihr das im Kühlschrank kühlt.
Ich liebe diesen Moment.
Uuuh, wie hübschi!
[Kiki] Richtig schick, der ist richtig hübsch!
[Hamza] Perfekt!
So, ich lasse mir jetzt ein Stückchen schmecken zusammen mit Hamza,
der hat nämlich gerade Kaffee gemacht, richtig schön frischen!
Und wir lassen den Abend jetzt ausklingen.
Euch ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen
und schreibt mir unbedingt in die Kommentare, was für Rezepte ich euch als nächstes zeigen soll.
Und die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen hier unten in der Videobeschreibung, das auch nochmal als Hinweis.
Hamza hast du noch was zu sagen?
[Hamza] Ich will probieren!
[Kiki] Ich auch!
Bis dann ihr Lieben, Tschüss!
Mmh, mh! Richtig lecker!
Unbedingt nachmachen! Ciao!